Charles C Johnson is the author of why
Coolidge matters leadership lessons from
America's most underrated president a
graduate of Claremont McKenna College
his writing has appeared in such
publications as The Wall Street Journal
the new criteria reason and the
Claremont Review of Books he has been
the recipient of the Robert L Bartley
fellowship and the Erik Bryan Dell award
at The Wall Street Journal the Robert
Novak award at the Phil foundation and
the Publius fellowship at the Claremont
Institute please join me in welcoming
Charles Johnson
so I want to thank you all for coming
here today it's quite an honor though
I'm not an alum of Hillsdale College I
often find myself wishing I were the
company of people I meet here I can take
some satisfaction in that many of my
professors or classmates or teachers of
the teachers at Hillsdale College but I
truly wish I had known of Hillsdale when
I actually applied to school many now
seems like many years ago Calvin
Coolidge of course was our last
classically educated president and I
think he would have felt right at home
in Hillsdale a school founded on the
truth that all are created equal and
which sent many of its best and
brightest to fight and even to die so
that Lincoln's hope that Wright might
make might make might might live hills
dales motto pursuing truth defending
Liberty is certainly something that
Coolidge would have embraced fittingly
for those of us who understand that
those who control the schoolhouse door
ultimately controlled the White House
our subject is education and what Calvin
Coolidge a neglected statesman has to
teach us about our contemporary politics
in our own political order as Tom Tom
silver the late president of the
Claremont Institute has shown Calvin
Coolidge wasn't so much silent as
silenced by the New Deal historians who
unable to argue with the successes of
his policies or the thought behind them
rewrote history to cast Coolidge as a
villain or to characterize him these New
Deal historians had their work cut out
for them
however Coolidge after all proceeded at
proceeded over one of the largest
expansions and economic growth in
American history and he had a lot to say
Coolidge gave over 500 press conferences
during his presidency he ran for office
19 times and 118 times working his way
up from city councilmen to President of
the United States truly a small R
Republican Statesman
the the last president he was the last
president to write his own speeches and
he penned three collections he published
a thoughtful autobiography after his
presidency and wrote a very successful
internationally syndicated post
presidential column my book why Coolidge
matters
is intended to faithfully report what
Coolidge actually had to say and what he
did say in the hope that we might
restore his views about limited
government American independence and
constitutionalism his thinking on
immigration civil rights foreign policy
government unions and especially liberal
education weren't considerable attention
by politicians today this is I believe
because Calvin Coolidge was a deeply
religious man he did not think a
republic was possible without moral and
religious education and he believed that
holy the holy writs command you shall
know the truth and it shall set you free
ought to be the guiding principle in in
all of our educational system as well as
our Republic America he argued was
founded by religious man it's finest
schools he reasoned we succeeded because
they taught to shape souls as well as
opinions and as we know great presidents
are products of their education Coolidge
knew well the value of education because
his political thought had been shaped at
Amherst where under the tutelage of its
most famous professor charles garmin a
professor of philosophy Coolidge learned
everything he needed to know about
politics William James called Garmin the
greatest teacher in the United States
and Coolidge absolutely loved him he
dedicated six pages of his very slim
autobiography to that old professor and
after he died Coolidge Coolidge's wife
were counted that Garmin's works sat on
his nightstand table throughout his
presidency
along with Paradise Lost and the Bible
Coolidge considered Garmin quote one of
the most remarkable men and quote with
whom he had ever come into contact he
drew men out Coolidge wrote referring to
himself Garmin students saw in him
qualities that they wish to develop in
themselves intellectual curiosity
tolerance and idealism some students did
develop those qualities and abundance
and Coolidge drew upon these men to form
his government in times of crisis Dwight
Morrow ambassador to Mexico William
whiting Secretary of Commerce and Harlan
F Stone Attorney General and later
Supreme Court justice never
philosophically and perhaps physically
far from his
there's lectures Coolidge never forgot
them or opposed their political
teachings Coolidge believed as Garman
did that choosing the right thing would
refresh the soul sharpen the mind and
bring it's just reward from Providence
in the here and now quote we looked upon
Garmin as a man who walked with God
Coolidge recalled his course was a
demonstration of the existence of a
personal God of our power to know him of
the divine eminence and of the complete
dependence of all the universe on him as
the creator and father in whom we live
and move and have our being
his reaction every reaction in the
universe is a manifestation of his
presence man was revealed as his son and
nature as the hem of His garment while
through a common fatherhood we were all
embraced in a common Brotherhood the
conclusions which followed from this
position were logical and inescapable it
sets man off in a separate Kingdom from
all the other creatures in the universe
and makes him a true son of God and
partaker of the divine nature this is
the warrant for man's freedom and the
demonstration of his equality it does
not assume all are equal in degree but
that all are equal in kind on that
precept rest foundation for democracy
that cannot be shaken this is a theme
that Coolidge would return to over and
over again throughout his presidency and
throughout his political career most
important for our purposes Garman taught
his students the religious basis for
Republican gov for republican government
reasoning that as we have a common
fatherhood and a common father and God
the Father we are brothers and therefore
only Republican government is possible
that men should live together in
community as Christ did as servants not
masters that politics doesn't mean
survival of the fittest but sacrifice of
the fittest that it means men giving up
their seats on the Titanic so that women
and children might live as Coolidge
noted and that these that's the central
teachings of the Declaration of
Independence that all men are created
equal need to be applied to the issues
of his day as well as I would argue to
our own Coolidge applied Garmin's ideas
and these ideas time and time again to
issues of civil rights for blacks women
and native
to immigration and how we might make
immigrants American to the impossibility
of public sector unions and a republic
where all are created equal and even to
foreign policy where he rejected the
kaisers pretension to rule the free men
and women of Europe and his first fights
of course with the ball service the
Bolsheviks who he refused to recognize
as the rightful rulers of Russia and
even Coolidge's more controversial acts
which we can if you feel free to discuss
in the question and answer period the
Immigration Act of 1924 the tariff and
his early progressivism have in their
origins his thinking on the declaration
to defend the Declaration Coolidge knew
that he would have to pull it too
politically defeat the nihilists of his
day the Klan New Genesis New Genesis the
Communists and the anarchists whose
campaign of bombing and agitation is
eerily similar to that which took place
earlier this week Coolidge did this but
by understanding that man has a
spiritual nature that those who adhere
to it will ultimately be triumphant even
in moments of despair quote touch that
spiritual nature and it will respond as
the magnet responds to the pole the most
quote the most spiritual document in
Coolidge's view was the declaration
Coolidge owing to his belief in divine
intervention uses high used highly
religious language when discussing it in
his eyes the document was quote a
miracle inspiring a reverence that
helped bring pilgrims of every nation to
America's Shores people at home and
abroad alike Coolidge said considered
Independence Hall a hallowed ground and
revered the Liberty Bell as a sacred
relic these symbols represent a
spiritual event and America had become
quote a holy land now I understand that
Hillsdale students read Coolidge's
speech on the hundredth anniversary of
the declaration signing but my my
favorite Coolidge speech on the
Declaration is the one he delivered at
the home of Daniel Webster on July 4th
1916 you know it's important to consider
that while some of Coolidge's language
might sound a bit for lack of a better
phrase neocon he really would have
agreed with John Quincy Adams idea that
while Americans are Friends of Liberty
everywhere they're custodians only of
their own nevertheless he thought that
our
principals could have their expression
in other regimes and indeed would
so with that I'll read I'll read a short
selection from that speech the events of
history may have added to the
Declaration but they have subtracted
nothing wisdom and experience have
strengthened the admiration of it time
and criticism have not shaken it but
however worthy of our reverence and
admiration
however preeminent it was only one
incident of a great forward movement of
the human race of which the American
Revolution was itself only a larger
incident it was not so much a struggle
of the colonies against the tyranny of
bad government as against wrong
principles of government and for
self-government
it was man realizing himself and
Coolidge Coolidge would go on that
realization persisted through time and
touched all men's souls as it moved from
Concord in Yorktown marching on to Paris
to London to Moscow to Peking men of
every clime respected the declaration
for quote it marked the entry of new
forces and new ideals into human affairs
it represented the realization of the
true glory and worth of man and
encouraged and encouraged by that noble
document man would would wrought vast
changes that have marked all history
since its day man's triumphal progress
through time owed much to consideration
of quote of as Coolidge put it natural
rights but as Coolidge reminds us
natural rights are not sufficient to
live by as Coolidge reminded the
audience in Webster's home the
preservation of these natural rights
requires an understanding of duty and
pledging to one another and the body
politic quote the signers knew that well
more important still the people whom
they represented knew it so they did not
stop there after asserting that man was
to stand out in the universe with a new
and supreme importance the governments
were instituted to ensure life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness they did
not shrink from the logical conclusion
of this doctrine true Republican men
understood politics as the sacrifice of
the fittest not the survival of the
fittest this homage to the Declaration
runs deep in his writings his first ever
speech his college prise s
and his finest speeches all mention it
Coolidge continued to return to the
declaration because it was both a
product of religion and education which
he called the twin supports of
civilization as he wrote to an
Episcopalian Sunday school teacher in
Washington DC in 1927 quote the
foundations of our society and our
government rests so much on the
teachings of the Bible that it would be
difficult to support them if faith in
these teachings would cease to be
practically universal in our country
Coolidge called for a really religious
revival in his day and perhaps I think
he would argue even in our own religious
teachings concerned as they are about
how man should live need to be universal
for America's Republic to endure now we
should remember that Coolidge was not
sectarian in this view I mean he so his
finest speeches are actually given to
group to Jewish groups into Catholic
groups that would not necessarily have
agreed with his more Protestant
orientation um but he did think that
religion was important as being a full
and equal citizen and Coolidge's view we
can deduce man's natural equality from
both reason and revelation and we can go
about the project of instituting a
government where men serve one another
on this point Coolidge quoted the
theologians of the death of the founding
particularly John Weiss who wrote that
democracy is Christ's government in
church and state
Weiss works were reprinted in 1772 and
according to Coolidge had been to quote
declared nothing less than a textbook of
Liberty for our revolutionary fathers
the founders and Coolidge's view believe
that ultimate sanction of law rests on
the righteous authority of the Almighty
I argue that religion the kuja's
religious faith and his education are
the ball works that actually prevent
prevented his mind from succumbing to
progressivism successes education he
told a convention of the National
Education of us of scholars excuse me
National Education Association in 1924
is the cornerstone of self-government
well religion keeps America inoculated
from dictatorship because Christ spent
no time in the antechamber of Caesar the
separation of governments and moral life
to
under Caesar that which is his and God
that would God that which hid that which
is his would keep America American after
all religion had strong ties to
America's Civil life in history it
needed to be cultivated quote our
government rests upon religion Coolidge
told the Boy Scouts of America religion
is the source from which we derive our
reverence for truth and justice for
equality and liberty and for the rights
of mankind and Coolidge the one group
that Coolidge did not believe could
could seriously be serious Republican
citizens were atheists and this was
because atheists didn't recognize
something higher than themselves
um even among the people who had been
sat had hitherto been savages religions
influence has always in everywhere
been a force for illumination and
advancement Coolidge gives a very
thoughtful speech on this point at
Howard University where he notes the
progress of blacks from effectively from
slavery and from backwardness as he puts
it in Africa to to being full and equal
citizens in the United States and he
says if it's possible to have this
political progress in America it's
possible to have it as well in Africa
and elsewhere throughout the world which
is something to consider and Coolidge's
view religion breaks down all barriers
of race or culture and replaces it with
concern for the universal new arrivals
could be Americanized he told an
assembly of the foreign-born if they
keep up their devotion to religion they
only become agreat only becomes
dangerous when people lose their faith
he feared that as the country grew less
religious our civilization might be lost
in dependence on government we cannot
depend on government to quote do the
work of religion because there is no way
by which we can substitute the authority
of law for the virtue of man trying to
get government to save souls rather than
to protect their rotted men's rights and
trusted them to save themselves to their
churches would ultimately lead to
tyranny this insight was why Coolidge
ultimately broke with the progressives
who held that progress in modern science
and never to believe meant progress in
political science and thus and overall
quality of life this argument of the
progressives under undergirded their
belief that the that
man was perfectible a notion that
Coolidge rejected out of hand at a
commencement address at a Catholic
College Holy Cross in in Massachusetts
we have quote no right to expect as our
portion something substantially
different from human experience in the
past the Constitution of the universe
does not change human nature remains a
constant it follows from this assertion
that the study of the classics which
speak to the speak to man's human nature
and have existed throughout the ages
teach important lessons to mankind for
coolidge men come to the study of the
classics because they as he told as he
told the American classical league
realized that the only road to freedom
lies through the through a knowledge of
truth something I think Hillsdale could
absolutely appreciate this love of
knowledge of truth something that
contemporary politicians especially
conservatives ought to consider taking
on for themselves Coolidge is right when
he says that every political party needs
to needs in some sense to be progressive
rather than reactive but how shall we
define progress reading Coolidge might
give people a good place to start
Coolidge's confidence in progress
according to the declaration of
independence paid political dividends he
got votes from blacks from Jews from
immigrants and from many others he went
anywhere to any audience and evangelized
he delivered the same declaration
inspired message politicians he noted
should avoid the politics of expediency
and stick to the politics of principles
perhaps contemporary politicians should
do as Hillsdale students do and read
Coolidge's speech on the declaration of
independence with which I'll close it is
often asserted that the world has made a
great deal of progress since 1776 that
we've had new thoughts and new
experiences which have given us a great
advance over the people of that day and
that we may therefore very well discard
their conclusions for something more
modern but that reasoning cannot be
applied to this Great Charter the
declaration if all men are created equal
that is final if they are endowed with
inalienable rights that is final if
governments drive their just powers from
the consent of the governed that is
final no advance no progress can be made
beyond these
propositions if anyone wishes to deny
their truth or their soundness the only
direction in which he can proceed
historically is not forward but backward
toward the time when there was no
equality no rights of the individual no
rule of the people those who wish to
proceed in that direction cannot lay
claim to progress
they are reactionary their ideas are not
more modern but more ancient than those
of our revolutionary fathers and with
that I'll take some questions
now I understand that there's a lot of
questions about Coolidge and that a lot
of what people think they know about it
may actually be wrong so you can feel
free to ask anything you want on
Coolidge and I'll try to my best to
answer it
Stuart Reuter how well-supported was
Coolidge by his own political party I
mean he came in as a vice president
under assassination conditions did he
have full support well in fact what we a
warren g harding was not assassinated he
he died but i mean to give you kind of a
sense of that Coolidge was very popular
in Massachusetts he was very popular
among the party faithful he was not
necessarily popular among sort of the
bigwigs of the party convention in fact
in in 1920 when the Harding Coolidge
ticket forms Coolidge was seen as
something of a Dark Horse that he was
not he was not he's not popular by the
sort of the the people in the
smoke-filled rooms so to speak but what
ended up happening of course was his
response to the police strike of 1919 in
which he rejected this idea that the
police officers could have a loyalty to
to a union over their loyalty as public
servants and that response of calling in
the National Guard of actually of
actually restoring order was very very
popular in the country as a whole so
that's what catapulted him to the vice
presidency now he was I mean during his
during his presidency he was very
popular among different different groups
from there there were Coolidge Democrats
back in in Boston who crossed lines
against what the the irish-american
Democrat leaders were were telling them
to do and part of that was because
Coolidge went door to door and actually
spoke to the Irish as fellow citizens
which is something that this sort of
club' New England politics of the Henry
Cabot Lodge --is and that so forth that
they did not do a very good job of
actually doing and so Coolidge actually
owes some of his successes particularly
early in his career
going out and knocking on doors and
doing the very sorts of retail politics
but to answer your question we're
generally he was very popular among the
among the party faithful the sort of you
know rank-and-file Republicans but he
was he was often distrusted by by sort
of the this the Senate leaders in the
Republican Party and particularly it's
interesting that to note when I tried to
go into this at some length from the
book the relationship with him and his
successor Herbert Hoover I'm sure we'll
get a question at some point about what
role what if anything what blame
Coolidge should get for the Great
Depression and it's interesting that
Coolidge criticized Herbert Hoover on
sort of free-market grounds he said that
for six years that man has given me
unsolicited advice as Commerce Secretary
all of it bad he could refer to him
dismissively as his wonder as this
wonder boy and when he's writing his
successful post presidential column he's
criticizing the socialistic notions of
government this is during the Hoover
administration he doesn't you know he
doesn't even have to wait until until
the administration of Franklin Delano
Roosevelt so I think it's interesting to
note that that Coolidge very much
understood some small our Republican
politics of going on talking to people
because he had to I mean he he started
as a city councilman worked his way all
the way up and there's not a taint of
corruption associated with him there's
sort of none of the sort of thing we
would expect to people who are machine
politicians in our day so I don't know
if that helps
thank you my question relates to his
economic and budget cutting policies I
coach was well known for using the veto
to get rid of all pork barrel spending
and many could look at him as an example
of where a Republican politician should
go today but many have said that the
circumstances are entirely different now
than they were in the 1920s so would it
be possible to have a president who is a
ruthless budget cutter like Coolidge was
today yeah I mean here's where I sort of
part company with my friend Emma D
Flay's who's written a good book on
Coolidge as well I believe that
Coolidge's budget cutting policies and
his fiscal policies were were the fruits
of more serious thinking about
government so for instance I believe
that he was in favor of limited
government rather than more libertarian
small-government and I think it helps to
a certain sentence to imagine that in
1920 when the Harding Coolidge ticket
gets and gets in most of the cuts that
that took place were in things like
defense spending now I don't know that
it's necessarily something we want to do
today that said I do think there is some
truth to using the veto pen to having
real responsibility over government to
making sure that it doesn't grow too
much because if government goes outside
of its bounds if it doesn't say stay
limited it often does very poorly
there's additional roles that takes up
for itself and I think Coolidge
understood as he put it that self
self-government means self support so
some of the things that we have today
say that Social Security you know
Medicare some of these these programs
that basically make people dependent on
government are things that he did he
opposed in his own day in his own way
those sorts of programs they didn't
really weren't quite the same thing but
he was against things like aid to
farmers he was against he was against
giving you know giving even flood relief
he thought that should that local
governments did it did it best and I
think that's something that conservative
politicians ought to consider as well I
mean during Coolidge's time a new local
government
very very well and we need to kind of
consider what are the policy what are
the principles that we can turn into
policies that will be effective at the
local government level because that you
know there is no the you know the the
bounds of what is permissible in local
government is is a lot I think larger
than the bounds of what is permissible
and at the federal level and that's
something that we should we should be
mindful and considerate
I wonder if you could just clear up a
point that was not clear to me and your
presentation and this is about the
connection between religion religion not
religious freedom on the one hand and
the Declaration of Independence on the
other so I thought what you were saying
was that natural rights which are in the
Declaration don't seem to be sufficient
for Coolidge and so Coolidge also
appeals through to religion the question
is is the appeal to religion outside of
or external to the declaration so that
the declaration is insufficient I don't
think he would go that far I think he
would keep I mean he speaks about their
many speeches I could come point to you
afterwards but there where he discusses
the declaration as a spiritual document
as the product of both enlightenment
thinking and the Great Awakening
thinking that it's sort of working in
tandem it's not it's not quite how to
put this it's not quite I mean the the
Declaration of Independence is its
Coolidge she's at a spiritual document
now is that a sectarian document that's
you know that's that's a larger question
you know it does it doesn't get to
actual natural rights can it be can't
you know can a non-christian or a non
judeo-christian actually be a loyal and
faithful citizen I don't think Coolidge
Coolidge did not take up that issue can
we you know can we be Republican
citizens manat quite address that at
that point he he does not see a division
that perhaps we think of today between
religious you know religion and the
teachings of Revelation and the
declaration he sees them as being as
being you know joined-at-the-hip
I don't know that it's helpful if not
pass the microphone to the gentleman yes
yeah um you took you spoke a little bit
earlier about his views on education in
terms of a citizenship and the need to
teach in those that come and immigrated
to the u.s. to become Americans I wanted
in light of the bill that's in the in
Congress now if you could touch more on
his philosophy of what type of
immigration the US should pursue sure I
mean one of the more controversial acts
of his presidency is the Immigration Act
of 1924 which set quotas on the numbers
of immigrants that could come to the
United States
now I actually defend this very
unpopular bill in the book on the
grounds that what Coolidge understood
and what some of the politicians of his
day understood is that there are certain
types of people who who can come to
America and assimilate and they're
certain ones that cannot he believed
that that perhaps some of the more
Bolshevist inspired ones of Eastern
Europe could not become full citizens
and that that kind of question I think
is something that we as kind of
conservatives need to need to think
about I mean there are certain put it
put it another way when Coolidge is
speaking about Norwegian Americans
coming and becoming full and equal
citizens that's that's a different sort
of immigrant than say somebody who is
from Chechnya right so that's something
that we we as conservatives need to
address and need to think seriously
about Coolidge believed that immigration
policy and foreign policy were linked
but he did not think about it in racial
terms while there were new Genesis there
were around him particularly the
Secretary of Labor Coolidge rejected
that kind of eugenics thinking he in
facts as a number of very positive
things about japanese-americans which I
also go into the book go in to in detail
in the book so he thought that that that
certain nations could be made or the
Nationals from certain nations could be
made American and that some could not
and that that
as he put it that a lot of the policies
around immigration that that it that in
effect that some groups how to put this
better that that while some groups could
assimilate others could not and I think
that's something that we need to
consider so at the same time that he's
doing that though the same time is
pushing those immigration bills he's
also making Native Americans all signing
an act that makes all Native American
citizens and he's joining their tribes
because he's trying to fuse the two
populations into an American home and at
the same time that he's you know that
they're restricting immigration he's
also calling for federal and Tooey he's
calling for a bill that limits the the
basically outlaws lynching because he
argues that states states rights don't
give you a right to do wrong so it's
it's a more complicated picture I don't
know what he would have thought of the
current immigration debate today I mean
I can tell you that I think we need to
have more emphasis on how do we make
people Americans rather than guest
workers or or voters so there's there's
the language that we had in the 1986
amnesty bill I don't think is is
currently talked about we don't talk
about how to assimilate people how to
make them part of America and I think
Coolidge from the record that he would
have he would have agreed with that we
have a question from an online viewer
Eric in Minnesota would like to know
four Coolidge was the Constitution a
living document no
thank you I think it's important I mean
happy you know Harry Jaffa and the
people to Claremont Institute do a very
good job of explaining that the
Constitution is basically the form that
gives life to the Declaration now
Coolidge Coolidge did not think that the
Declaration was the only document that
you could that that of importance I mean
he would have listed you know the Bible
he would have listed a number of things
that we think of this cloud being
classically educated in you know the the
he would have listed you know a number
of documents that we think of today as
important documents in our political
thought but no absolutely not I mean
there's no there's no way one could see
the Constitution he says to live under
the United States Constitution is the
greatest privilege ever afforded to the
human race I don't think that means you
should tinker with it
hi thank you what I just like if you
could maybe comment about Coolidge's
view of how politicians should conduct
themselves in the character with which
they should conduct themselves and I
just is a preamble huh give you a couple
quotes that I pulled together for a
little introduction to a book that we
published on of Coolidge's writings and
one was a quote by Cal Thomas who said
that quote politics in the end is not
about drama but about principle not
about charisma but about character and
Richard Norton Smith said to most
Americans Coolidge was more than a
character he was character to most
voters he was leader a leader of rare
integrity and immovable principled just
wondered if he could make some comments
about yeah I mean I think it's important
to stress Coolidge's tragic view of
human nature when kind of thinking about
this point he comes from Plymouth notch
Vermont which even today is sort of a
remote part of Vermont
he is from not quite poor but not quite
wealthy I mean sort of small are
everyone sort of equal sort of citizens
stalk and he did not think of himself as
a great man he referred to himself he he
said that after his presidency he very
much wanted to return to life and
Plymouth nagy he Archon Northampton you
know right after his presidency he also
understood that the words of the
president have tremendous weight and
they ought not be squandered that if you
go and run your mouth all the time as
president that will cause problems for
you and so he had a sense of his own
limitations and part of this I think is
he he understood that that life is not
always what we want it to be I mean when
he was growing up his mother died and
his sister and when he was president his
boy died while he was while he was in
the Oval Office he got a blood blister
and he died I mean there was sort of no
notion of a right to health care right I
mean you just you know that what we
expect and demand
today was not possible during Coolidge's
day and so I think it's important to
kind of consider when we think about
Coolidge as a man that he had a sense of
his own limitations and that may be
limited government needs people who
understand that they're they're just you
know they put their pants on one leg at
a time like the rest of us that they
don't behave like princes and I think to
kind of contrast him with President
Obama I think that's the you know the
contrast is sort of night and day that
President Obama does think of himself as
a great man I mean Coolidge very rarely
took vacations and when he did he was
working in those vacations I think
that's that's something that we we need
to kind of can go back to but I think if
you if you don't teach people the
virtues of tolerance and of you know
frugality that you will produce people
who are narcissistic politicians who
want to get everything they can out of a
system and I think that you know
contemporary politics bears that out
as I understand it Calvin Coolidge is
the first president after Lincoln the
first Republican President or first
President of any of any either party
that really emphasized the Declaration
of Independence and all men are created
equal and we haven't had very many
Republican or Democratic presidents
since his term except for perhaps Ronald
Reagan who really had that emphasis and
my question is what happened we had
seven or eight Republican presidents
between Lincoln who based so much of his
policy on the proposition that all men
are created equal what happened and
continues to have happened well I think
part of this is an education problem and
as I try to argue Coolidge was the last
classically educated president and I
think it's important to understand that
Coolidge would spend all this time
reading I mean he you know there there
mentions of him at Amherst reading the
Federalist Papers and reading reading
about about Hamilton and about Lincoln I
think what Coolidge you know Coolidge in
many respects was Lincoln with Lincoln
with a college degree and I think it's
important to kind of understand that
from that as Coolidge saw it and as I
think I I mean as I see it more politics
runs from the Declaration the American
Founding to Abraham Lincoln to
Coolidge's Day and then of course
Coolidge was Reagan's favorite president
and I'm about to fight to publish an
essay soon on Reagan Reagan's
involvement with you know Reagan's
understanding of Coolidge having gone to
the Reagan Library and that so if we
want to go back to conservatives are
always wondering how do we get back to
Reagan how do we go back to the that
glory you know that glorious time I
think what we could do is we could
actually go back and look at Coolidge
because Coolidge we know influenced
reagan's thinking but when as Reagan
grew up as a boy he listened to Coolidge
on the radio Coolidge was a very shy man
who who relied on radio to get his
message out and I think that's something
weak we need to kind of consider
as conservatives now I don't know I
don't know quite what happened between
Abraham Lincoln's day and Coolidge's I
do know that Coolidge very much made a
big deal politically of his ties to
Lincoln so for instance in the campaign
of 1924 the the people who are running
the campaign for Coolidge were
encouraged to go to every small town and
get a list of all the Civil War veterans
as as an endorsement of the Coolidge
campaign so Coolidge very much thought
of himself in line I think part of it is
is reconstruction I think there there
was a desire by a number of people not
to go back and read the refight old
fights I think a lot of it was just the
poor education of the Republican
presidents that followed between Lincoln
and Coolidge they were not possibly many
of them were not as I would say his
classically educated as Coolidge yes
well George Bush mentioned the
Declaration of Independence many times
but I think the problem there is that it
was a living declaration of independence
and so it was used in ways that didn't
relate to the limited government notion
that the Declaration through the notion
of government of consent makes makes
quite clear and I'd relate that to a
defense very very partial of the phrase
living Constitution because I think
where it comes from is the notion of a
never living goal I mean it's sort of a
secularization of that notion and so
that is a constancy the notion of an
eternity and everliving God what the
people who use the term living
Constitution means is one that you could
simply make things up as you go along
and
and and so I think what we need to do is
in our reverence for the Constitution
make it clear that it applies to to all
men at all Americans at all times and we
need to be care be careful of the way we
use the declaration as well in that you
know it has eternal meaning I would
agree with that I mean I would say that
what's what's important and Coolidge's
political thought is when he goes and as
a young man he's progressive and he you
know he votes for things that that it
would perhaps put him closer to Teddy
Roosevelt than perhaps Taft or others he
votes for things like the the direct
election of senators he votes for he
votes for women's or he's in favor of
women's suffrage and I think what's
interesting about how he explains his
defensive of sort of progress as he
always explains it in declaration terms
so that if you if you partake of
actually fighting a war as the Indians
did in in in World War one that
therefore you have that you are if you
are taking up the duties that you
therefore have the rights and I think
conservatives often think of the
declaration or at least the sort of more
neocon variety they don't understand and
that the form of government matters
tremendously that while these principles
are eternal how one structures
government is you know that's where the
that's where the the Devils in the
details and I don't think I don't think
that sort of President Bush understood I
don't think he understood that the
American experiment in self-government
was extremely complicated I think he
took too low a view of it and how easy
it could be transplanted or its
principles could be transplanted and I
think that's something the Coolidge
would have understood as well because of
his understanding of religion and of of
a Greek and Latin education but yeah I
mean you meet you raise a very important
point about the living the living
Constitution I think one thing we as
conservatives can do and is is try and
understand progress and the amendments
and so forth
think think in those terms think of
progress in declaration with the
declaration in mind hi and thanks for
being here we really appreciate it as a
Hillsdale College student I've been
privileged to be able to you know read
some of the speeches you mentioned and
learn a bit more about some things that
I most certainly didn't know growing up
and I know we have some high school
students here so my question is can you
explain our please if you can't explain
the tax cuts in as quickly as you can
but also perhaps a couple policy
initiative initiatives of has that most
people don't understand or don't know
about and that might be relevant today
sure well I think it's important that
when you cut taxes you also cut the size
and scope of government I think
conservatives by and large have tried to
pull a fast one and think that you can
just cut taxes well that may be true in
the short run I don't think it's true
overwhelming you know you can't you
can't cut taxes on the one hand and keep
promising people things like
prescription drug benefits I don't think
that works I think it may be politically
effective in the short run but in the
long run I think it's Coolidge said it's
the politics of expedience it gets you
into trouble I do think that I mean kind
of to get at the larger the larger
question of the tax cuts I think they
were part of a of an overall toolkit
that was developed by Coolidge with his
Treasury secretary Andrew Mellon to to
you know to stimulate the economy but he
he did it not because for more kind of
libertarian grounds he did it because
the government didn't need the money so
on the one hand you know Coolidge is
cutting their connieyc they were hunting
defense during the early part of the
1920s and Coolidge's is trying to
negotiate
with the Japanese his secretary of state
is trying to go she with the Japanese
and with the British to actually reduce
naval naval arms but towards the tail
end of his presidency in March 1929 he
recognizes that that we need to do
something about what's going on in the
country or what's going on in the world
and so he signs the bill the effect that
creates the first aircraft carrier and
creates a lot of the battleships so a
lot of it is you know you need to
understand that at certain periods in
time certain decisions make a lot of
sense but at other times they don't and
we're always trying to take the policies
and just reapply them and I don't think
that works I think you need to think
more about the principles to get how to
think about the problems seriously and
prudential ii before you actually
execute them i know if that's if that
helps
well I think it's fair to say I mean I
would recommend other books on this more
than my own but my understanding of it
is that effectively as mellon friedman
said we had a federal reserve that that
wasn't up to the task that effectively
it had created an inflationary economy
and that many of the problems that we
associate with the 1920s were caused by
the Fed now I have sort of my view on
this is that while it's true that there
was an inflationary economy it's also
true that there were a number of goods
and services produced then that we still
use all the time today I mean cars you
know radios that you Coolidge's of
course the first president to be on film
so it wasn't quite like the inflationary
period of the 1990s for instance where
everybody bought homes they couldn't
afford they actually there were actual
real things produced I think it's
important to understand as well the
Henry Ford Thomas Edison Harvey
Firestone the sort of industrial Titans
of the day all endorsed and like
Coolidge and met with him and associated
themselves with it so I think if I were
to say what caused a lot of the the
Great Depression is I would say that
Roosevelt prolonged it that that in
effect if you look at the the recession
of 1919 and 1920 that was actually a
more severe recession that the Harding
Coolidge ticket dealt with by doing
essentially nothing and that I think a
lot of people assumed in 1929 that it
was the same sort of situation and I
think government policy particularly
policy of Herbert Herbert Hoover and of
Franklin Delano Roosevelt truly may put
the great in the great depression so
Coolidge of course even in 1932 there's
a draft Coolidge campaign people still
thought he had things to say and to do
and to teach
he of course dies in 1933 so I think
it's it's important to understand him
you know when he deals with Herbert
Hoover they're both Republicans and
Coolidge owes all of his political
assess success to being a good
Republican you know Republican party
party
and so he was not going to go out
publicly and cause all these problems
but nevertheless and his in his post
residential call him he does criticize
the policies of the Hoover
administration he does criticize a
number of other sort of you know big
government Republican policies of the
day and I think that that's part of the
story has not been told satisfactorily
who do you feel might be the caravel
Calvin Coolidge in the nineteen sixteen
election nineteen Oh 2016 it's gonna say
yes I met I met a gentleman two weeks
ago who turned 101 and he remembers
Calvin Coolidge so it's quite something
to talk with him but as for 2016 I mean
I'm senator Ted Cruz did endorse my book
so I would I'd be remiss if I didn't
mention him but I do think I mean there
was a reason I asked him right I mean
Harvard Harvard educated our Harvard
credentialed but more seriously educated
I don't think Harvard is was quite the
place it was and Coolidge's day or
perhaps John Adams his day for sure but
I think he's perhaps one he's a very
serious thinker I would even say if Rand
Paul were to get over his more
libertarian inclinations insofar as he
doesn't do a good job of explaining why
they're actually limited government
impulses rather than than libertarian
impulses I think that would be better I
don't know that he would necessarily be
my first pick but I mean to a certain
extent we have a serious problem because
we don't take seriously higher education
we don't take seriously shaping young
people's you know souls and minds and I
think we're in for some serious trouble
in the country I think that's being born
out now and I think it's going to get a
lot worse before it gets better you know
and I think probably many of the reasons
I like Hillsdale and if I know my alma
mater Claremont McKenna College is that
to it to a very large extent it actually
teaches these things seriously
the principles of the Declaration being
classically educated and if we continue
to produce people who who think only in
terms of a policy and of the politics of
the moment of the kind of the Twitter
culture that we're not going to be
successful we need to have people who
think strategically about where the
country is now and where it needs to be
rather than by day by day politics and
year by year elections because I think
those will follow if we have the policy
of the principles seriously considered
didn't Coolidge ever criticize later in
life the progressive amendments that
really kind of enabled interventionist
government like direct election of
senators or income tax or sure well I
mean it's important to understand like
the income tax is one of you know in
terms of scope it was not I think it was
much much lower than it was than it is
today very few people paid it that the
people who did pay it I mean during
Coolidge's presidency this is something
that actually I've enjoyed you know kind
of mocking some of my more left-wing
friends about that the tax rates
actually got more progressive under
Coolidge even though he cut them so for
instance the rich paid more in taxes
partly because of a booming economy but
but I think you know you raise an
interesting point
I mean Coolidge starts his career as a
as sort of a city councilman but Alto
but then a legislature and he becomes
president of the Massachusetts State
Senate and he realizes that hey we were
just producing too many bills that we
have to give administration a chance to
catch up and of course later on when he
becomes governor and ulta and ultimately
president he has that same sort of
inclination that he he sort of he has a
sort of shrink in his view of what
government can possibly do and I think
as kind of conservatives we should think
about that that the the character of the
office shapes the policies and how you
think about the problem many of the
issues that we're dealing with today
that are a consequence of sort of the
progressives amendments were not
we're not fully understood or fully
suffered at the time nevertheless I do
talk about this in the book about the
foreign policy I do think that the
foreign policy considerations with the
direct election of senators that what
happened was you got foreign policy that
was a lot less sober that would
effectively what was happening is people
were campaigning in their own districts
or their own states with the immigrant
groups and trying to create policies
that would favor them rather than it
would previously favor the states so
you've got to remember at certain point
at a certain point in the 1920s you have
people who are directly elected and you
also people who are brought there by to
represent their states and so create a
kind of an interesting dynamic
particularly in foreign policy that I
think kulish appreciate it but he never
he never to my knowledge spoke out
against the income tax amendment he of
course thought taxes should be low but
that was to have limited government not
because you know he was there was some
sort of principled objection to the
income tax oh yes so prohibition is
actually really interesting I I regret
that I did not go into prohibition and
the detail it deserves in the book
because prohibition so Coolidge believed
that all the lower state the states like
in Massachusetts and others that wanted
to effectively ignore prohibition or
create their own kind of local laws he
thought that what they were doing is
they were doing a disservice to the law
you know writ large and so while he we
know that many of the members of his
administration drank Andrew Mellon among
them he was he was not one to do that
maybe it's because you know some people
think that warren g harding died because
he liked to drink but I think it's it's
interesting that the way he deals with
the problem of prohibition as he saw it
as sort of an overreach but yet his job
as president and his a political figure
was to and was to enforce the law so I
think were word up to Coolidge I mean he
was campaigning in irish-american areas
people knew him in his early political
career as as more a wet than a dry but
he was not I think he would have agreed
with say Lincoln's speech on
the Temperance Society I think he would
have been more inclined with that kind
of thinking about the issue of
prohibition that helps and we have time
for one more question
two years after Coolidge died there was
this huge tocqueville revival on the
hundredth anniversary of his book and
I'm wondering whether Coolidge ever
mentions Tocqueville given their
interest in religion well we we know
from Amherst College he doesn't mention
in his in his autobiography even though
he mentions all the other books used
right we do know that he read
Tocqueville we don't know I couldn't
find any mention of it when I was
looking for it myself because I wanted
to sort of compare Coolidge's upbringing
in Plymouth notch to kind of Tocqueville
as description of small our Republic in
life but we there's not a lot of it I
mean I would say he was Tocqueville II
in but not necessarily inclined to quote
Tocqueville we do know that actually he
was very admired by of by French
thinkers who did quote Tocqueville in
Coolidge's context which is interesting
there's a guy Andre seek lead who wrote
a book sort of doing an update of who of
certainly he considered himself sort of
writing the appendix for you know for
the for democracy in America and he
wrote it in the 1920s and he compares
Coolidge all throughout with Washington
with other other figures it's well worth
reading I you know I have a there you
can get it for like ten cents on Amazon
so it's well worth checking out even for
you
you know just an afternoon thanks for
having me